all right who am i who am i home oh my
oh my
you're me when i'm touching myself
no ew what no dude i'm doing
sam's face when he's like conflicted
about something or really intense
no you're doing what i do when i
masturbate we're going to watch the
supernatural season 5 bloopers today
because we just finished supernatural
season 5 doing a whole podcast review
based off the questions from the
patronage for seasons one through
five that should be up now actually or
sometime today during these times i want
to say a really sincere thank you to
everyone who's been showing their
support over at our patreon page
you know right now times can be really
tough so really appreciate you guys
showing that extra support our way helps
keep the channel alive thank you
over at our patreon we have a weekly q a
podcast and then we also do tv show
reaction watchalongs and you sync up
with the time code
several of those shows also have the
option with reaction
highlights reaction highlights mean
footage included and those shows are
supernatural
doctor who joe joe's bizarre adventure
the promised neverland
attack on titan death note my hero
academia code geass hunter hunter one
punch man full of alex broner violet
and demon slayer and then there are
shows where we only do the watch-a-longs
for them agents of shield gotham and a
whole bunch of other ones let's watch
these bloopers dammit
well i say no guts no glory
i say
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
[Music]
yes
bastards
why they goof around so much
[Music]
that was cool to see the actual
dance
you are so close
[Music]
you walk away edges paige and
who
that'll
i walked up and night down some damn
reason
i'm sore
whoa last time you zapped me someplace i
didn't poop for a week
i need better scotch to go with that
this is fun
let's get that that's right that's blood
work ask what
[Music]
we're gonna have a good time
[Music]
oh yeah
[Music]
yes
[Music]
oh yeah
oh he's british tomorrow
somebody
[Music]
oh man scoob so i jerk off jensen onto
the ground
and then i give him a shot in the face
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
do you know about this about sam's
genius plan on how to jam the devil back
in the box
oh
we're gonna pop them in the hole
[Music]
sorry
oh boy
finally useful
[Music]
okay
there's a bottle of old cabinets
[Music]
is
confetti it's a parade
totally not cool
[Music]
oh set photos yeah
[Music]
i like that crow
i think there'd be some tricks during
here huh yeah
shut up once or twice but you think
there'd be more
stunt doubles
this makes me wish we could have worked
on the show
[Music]
hey
oh you blue screen that
[Music]
that's really great that they highlight
the crew yeah
i bet this played at a wrap party
congratulations kripke era
[Applause]
shook the devil's hand my goodness
myspace.com swank
hell yeah we're only 10 years behind on
this one
and you can probably still download that
song though uh these guys are really a
family unit we'll keep this short
there's not much to talk about
other than the fact that so much to
break we always have
we like to do the supernatural videos
where we're like talking about
everything forever seriously if you
check out our reviews
20 to 30 minutes on average per episode
we haven't
done the review yet that we're gonna
shoot it right after this uh
i'm very excited to talk about it i'm
actually glad we it was kind of a toss
up today like should we shoot the
reverser and then watch this or watch
this and shoot the review and i feel
like this is like a great button to put
on it with eric kripke leaving the show
or handing it off i think that's a
better terminology for this case handing
it off after season five and telling
what he felt like was the most he could
get
out of his tank i thought it was great
it was freaking amazing it's fantastic
what a trajectory that went down yeah
seriously
to see the family that's built i can
imagine how hard it was for
like as much as this all focuses you
know mainly on jensen
misha jim beaver there's someone i'm
missing
yeah you know sam
as much as it focuses on them yeah it's
you know like
kripke being the helm of this this is
like a family unit you know cast
and crew all together you usually keep
the same kind of crew for years
i imagine it's a hard position to let go
of it something that you
you know gave birth to and then now you
have to be like all right
sail on without me lying a little bird
yeah because we haven't
listened to that recent interview as
much people have been like there's no
spoilers so like i'm
gonna do my best and still avoid it you
know because he did some interview
recently watching this family unit and
even seen like
we've seen it in the convention videos
but especially in this bloopers like the
level
of looseness that misha collins has
developed
oh yeah throughout the series it's just
so tangible here yeah it's fun to watch
that set in over the course of a couple
of these blooper reels because you know
jensen and jared have that
quality already you know that you could
see from the even the first blooper reel
we watched but yeah to see
the way a show can grow behind the
scenes i think is always just a fun
little fly on the wall experiment
because
i remember the first blooper reel it
wasn't even that long was it and now
it's like it seems like there's a wealth
of
fun stuff to pull from across their
montages now
yeah exactly and i did appreciate yeah
that they put in even the the stills of
the uh crew
like i'm i'm almost certain that this
probably played at their season five
wrap party or something like that
because it is very sort of in the family
but i also think that's really neat
because every show is a chronicle of a
bunch of people's time and efforts the
joyous experience what these guys have
done
through that a lot of [ __ ] jokes
apparently yeah who would have thought
with a
with a cast and crew with mainly guys on
set but you get a lot of gay jokes in
there
hey man i'm sure that there's been a
three-way cuddle pile between the
the j2m no matter what's happened get
richard speight in there maybe a little
crowley
i can never be friends with any of these
guys they'd hate me i'd only ask them
about supernatural
weirdly they'd all they'd want to talk
about it yeah
i breathed it for 15 years yeah here i
come trying to talk about my bloody
belly
time or friday the 13th they're like no
no no
maybe maybe have some wax cause it's in
season five
but otherwise no all right guys well
what do you think of the crippy era of
supernatural leave your thoughts down
below make sure to check out our patreon
page subscribe to the real rejects click
that notification bell last but not
least
paul pj this guy was always in our live
streams consistently there showing his
support really do appreciate that
brother pandey
pandamik jones is one of his other
nicknames and then now
he is now part of our patreon page and
really grateful to have you here dude
every once in a while we talk about him
possibly starting up his own youtube
channels and he you know watches
us religiously i'm gonna say that i'm
saying that he hasn't said that i'll say
it
watches us devotedly and then he watches
a lot of other channels who are similar
to us a lot in the movie sphere and he
has a passion for this so pj
i'm going to encourage you to start up
your own youtube channel
do it start it up and then if it's
anything similar to ours
i'm gonna talk with my people at youtube
to make sure we shut your ass down
yeah there's already so many people
doing this now we can't have an
overfluctuation as it is already so pj
be careful because as much as i'm
encouraging you
i'm also threatening you star turf pj
that's how i roll
i am never happy ever
except when i'm talking to you in
messages but then when i think about the
future and our messages
i just don't get it
thanks for being part of our patreon
page pj peace